[Music]
thank you
coming up can you spot a walrus from
space how you can help these animals
survive climate change using satellite
images
[Music]
why do one in three children never leave
the city for a day in the countryside
foreign
hi this is FYI and we've been
investigating the latest news to help us
all get our heads around it and that
includes looking out for fake news
the Prime Minister has been fined for
not wearing a seat belt after police
officers saw this social media post of
him breaking the law is this fake or
fact and check out this viral video of a
cloud formation in the shape of praying
hands a Divine message or fake video
we've been investigating and will reveal
all later
happened
on the 27th of January every year is
Holocaust Memorial day but we are asked
to remember the millions that were
murdered or treated really badly in
conflicts because of their culture
religion disability or sexuality the
worst example of that happened during
the second World War
the German Nazi party led by Adolf
Hitler murdered six million Jewish
people who were from countries across
Europe in an attempt to wipe out the
entire Jewish population it is known as
the Holocaust
the Jewish people have done nothing
wrong they were targeted simply because
they were Jewish
[Music]
survived the Terrible
kill Jews she's now 98 years old but
that doesn't stop her from hitting
social media to tell her story with help
from her great grandson dove they think
it's important that we learn about the
Holocaust so it can never happen again
[Music]
how nice it would be for the whole world
if we would live in peace with each
other
I have seen the destruction I have seen
the verse I have went through hell
hunger is when you have nothing to eat
days after days after days
you must have been very very strong or
mentally or physically or boss
to survive
[Music]
everyone who survived is a miracle
so here's the fact we found one in three
children who live in cities never go
into the countryside me personally I
live near the center of London so I
didn't really see the countryside that
much yeah well like you I live in the
middle of Sheffield and I'm surrounded
by the most beautiful countryside
probably in the whole country but we
just never get out there I mean the cost
of petrol or train tickets could be the
reason money's tight for a lot of
families right now but it means missing
out on Fresh Air interacting with
animals and it's an escape from city
life but how about bringing the
countryside to the city to fire viewers
wanted to report on a project that does
just that for them
I'm Grace and I'm Theo and we're at
opening Horse Club in Brixton
[Music]
opening Horse Club is a youth club
riding Center where young people ride
and I have opportunities to experience
what it's like in the horse industry
ready for a little sponge Avenue Horse
Club is a charity where people from a
disadvantaged area can have chances that
they would never have had before
I genuinely believe that if it wasn't
for this horse riding club I don't know
where I would end up living in Brixton
is great because there's so much
diversity however it does present some
challenges for example the gang culture
it is quite difficult sometimes to be
living in an estate that especially when
it's dark you're kind of scared to go
through at home at night if I live
literally in the heart of Angel town so
left right and Center I'm seeing bad
influence
person can be very dangerous I've had so
many friends that have been like robbed
to a friend of mine I got his phone
stolen and like they're literally hold
their knife up to him so it's it's nice
for people like me to have a safe space
there's a range of activities that you
can do here for example jumping we do a
bit of dress art there's also a
volunteering aspect as well where you
can come in you don't have to ride but
you just help out with other young
people which is something that's very
unique about ebony
this place is my happy place so as soon
as I walk through the gates whatever has
happened outside of the gates I can just
let it go and just enjoy the time that
I'm having here
go horses I prefer them to people
because I feel like they get me before I
came to ebony I wasn't really good at
socially sometimes with other people I
got bullied a bit after coming to ebony
I gave so much confidence in myself my
favorite horse is Joe the thing about
him when I'm riding him you have to be
very gentle with him
because he gets a bit scared sometimes
we developed characteristics and skills
that I don't think I would have ended up
developing patience self-control the
horses really forced that patience into
you oh gosh Rose babe you're gonna have
to suck it in yeah
[Music]
I got number one yes whoa
if you have a story and want to report
on FYI get in touch via our webpage or
even better get your teacher to set up
an FYI News Club at your school members
get the chance to report for us we'll
even help you film Your Own Story you
can watch and discuss the latest
episodes with free resources every week
next how you can help save the walrus
which are under threat from climate
change warmer temperatures mean the
Arctic and Antarctica are in meltdown
putting walrus and other animals that
live there at risk so the animal
conservation charity WWF is asking us to
do some detective work and look for
walrus from space you heard me right all
you need to do is download their app
like us if you're under 13 you need your
parents consent to do that so let's try
it out okay so we have this is the
picture here yeah and it's like a little
Zoo oh yeah you can probably zoom in so
I'm guessing that if they were war I
said then it would be these so the app
gives you loads of different satellite
images from space of vast areas and you
have to identify whether there are
walruses there or if there's no walrus
or different Wildlife but sometimes it
can be really difficult because the
walrus might look like rocks or other
wildlife and you have to be careful on
if you're identifying them right you
have to try to see how how many are here
like you have to track out there could
be there could be 10 there could be one
there could be zero hits so we have to
try find doubt yeah and sometimes they
come in like mobs or sometimes it's just
like scattered about like on beaches
along like the shore but sometimes they
do come in like so yeah little bit
clumps yeah
oh they're definitely wore us this
picture definitely has some more recipes
yeah there's no way you have to like
walrus
I think I do it
about 30 and 40 on the honest one yeah
so how does counting Warriors numbers
from space help save them from climate
change we need to do this
foreign
so Hannah from the British Antarctic
Survey has come to tell us more hi
hi Scarlett hi jariah so how does
counting Warriors numbers from space
really help anything it helps big time
because Warren's
rely on CIS heavily they live in the
Arctic and sea ice in the Arctic is
melting much faster than anywhere else
on the planet they rely on it they
usually like to go on CIS to give birth
to that's where they come and rest
between feeding troops
and so we want to know what this is
going to mean for them like are they
going to be able to adapt yes or no but
you to see this we need to get an
understanding of numbers and flashlight
images over one season can allow us to
study their numbers in all of the places
where they know they are and then the
other great thing is we satellite you
don't disturb them because Warriors tend
to get bespooked by boat noises or play
noises well it's amazing that members of
the public can get involved and have a
go at counting Wars themselves is so
you're a massive help to the wars
because it's a lot of data to go through
for the few scientists that gets to
study them
and by you giving a bit of your time to
go through it you then held the science
that it's then going to inform the
conservation measure to help Safeguard
their future well you're doing such
amazing work and it seems like a really
great plan so thank you so much for
speaking to us you're welcome
[Music]
you said no one goes to the cinema
anymore I'll be chatting to the stars of
the box of the Smash Hit Puss in Boots
The Last Wish
[Music]
international players for Wales men's
and women's football teams will be paid
the same after a campaign for Equal Pay
but check this the Football Association
of Wales agreed to a 25 pay cut for the
men's team so they can raise the same
amount for the women's side nice one
[Music]
can you believe it the last adventure in
the Shrek Universe was more than 10
years ago Puss in Boots his back but he
discovers that his passion for adventure
has burned through eight of his Nine
Lives the legend will never die I dialed
up the famous faces behind the
characters voices I am person but person
boots is such a strong character what
elements of him do you see in yourself
and what parts of his personality do you
wish she had more of I don't know if I
am so heroic in my personal life as he
is I think I'm a loyal person too and I
think I'm honest too
so there are certain things of course
that I think I have but there are other
side to him you know I am not so
courageous
oh I have got to learn how to do that
there's a new Dynamic which is the dog
who joins this story your Puss in Boots
you have this new Trio Kitty when she
meets this adorable puppy she does not
trust him she thinks he's like a con
artist or something
trust me you gotta trust him look at
those eyes are you call that cute
with the pause it's all so cute would
you prefer more in voice acting in
comparison to film acting you are more
free you are not attached to your own
body hey you want to see something cool
obviously we have a lot of issues going
on in the world right now if you had One
Last Wish would they be I believe that
one of the problems we're leaving today
is that people are too busy creating
their opinion if we really connected to
the humanity in US it would be easier
to have compassion for others you know
and be thoughtful about other people's
situation when you only have one life
that's what makes it special we don't
have nine lives
we have just one and we have to
appreciate it and so through the
character of this little kitty cat we
can actually see a reflection of
ourselves go get him figure hey take it
easy
so did you spot the fake news well the
Prime Minister has been fined by the
police for not wearing a seatbelt in a
moving car the evidence was this social
media post that he posted
we find a statement from Rishi sunak
apologizing for his mistake
and this viral video of a cloud
formation in the shape of praying hands
is fake
while Some Cloud shapes can trick the
mind the only trick here is digital
editing based on this painting
[Music]
by the way happy year of the rabbit
we've just seen in the first day of a
new year of the Chinese lunar calendar
which is dedicated to one of 12 animals
every year did you know that on the 25th
of January every year people in Scotland
celebrate Burns night it marks the
birthday of a famous Scottish poet
Robert Burns Zoe who is the FYI News
Club member at her school wanted to tell
us a little bit more about this
so why does Robert Burns get so much
attention in Scotland well he's our
national book where um but he wasn't
actually famous while he was alive he
was famous after he died one of the
poems or songs that you might know is
Uncle anxiety as it's known all over the
world oh yeah Old Land signs a song that
everyone sings at midnight or New Year's
well our parents did so how do you
celebrate his birthday
um we celebrate it by having a bone
supper which we'll be having in school
on Friday where we eat haggy Snips and
tatties have some shortbreads and iron
Bros some traditional Scottish treats
we'll recite Scottish poems and songs
and then if we have time we'll have a
weekly to finish off sorry what is
Kaylee he really is um Scottish country
dancing to a traditional Scottish music
thank you so much for your info
hopefully you enjoy your poems your food
have a nice day it sounds like a lot of
fun thanks bye bye
and we finish with the news that Tim
Peake Britain's first European Space
Agency astronaut is to hang up his
spacesuit he's retiring after some
amazing adventures in space that made
him a hero to many of us and did you
know he did an exclusive interview on
the very first edition of FYI which is
four and a half years ago with a very
young Braden and what better way to
celebrate his achievements with a clip
from The Archives
how did you feel when you arrived that's
where I'm I live down there and I can
now see it that that view that you're
looking down there I mean when you see
the first view of planets out it's
mesmerizing and you could spend the
whole day just looking out the window
and you wouldn't get bored
today is about to give me a little tour
this is the crew quarter there's a kind
of the sleeping bag you see that we can
actually put our arms through there yeah
so you can be zipped up in your sleeping
bag but still let your arms float around
if you want to I could not sleep
[Music]